各位領導和老師同學
首先簡單介紹一下自己
我是螞蟻新河的小微金融平台技術部的張宏
今天數據要素可信流通技術穆克的分享主體是
多方聯合建模助力普惠信貸
核心內容源於我在以往信貸工作中的實戰經驗
同時也融入了行業標竿案例中
已經驗證的一些內容
以及方向探索和思考總結
希望通過對技術選型以及相應效果驗證等的
剖析為同行提供可附用的參考各方式
分享中若有不足之處
恳請各位專家不令執政期待與大家的深度探討
今天的主題分為留下幾個部分
首先是普惠金融的痛點與挑戰
然後是相關政策的指導和標準規範
這就是隱私融合計算方案的選擇
最後是多方聯合建模的信貸的事件
首先我們一起來看一下普惠金融的痛點與挑戰
在服務小微客體客戶群體時
我們面臨的一個雙重困境
一方面小微的客戶面臨的融資困
融資貴融資曼服務體驗差等的問題
他們缺自己的支廠譬如說房廠還有設備做抵押
缺信用記錄支撐貸款
甚至戳不起複雜的稅單合同
在被銀行拒絕後往往被迫借民間高利貸
年化20%以上的利息還是對他們生活構成了很大的影響
新銀的3G不等人一筆貸款拖上好幾周
生意可能就受了影響
另外一方面金融機構也頭疼
既怕壞賬不敢放貸
又因為人工禁調的成本很高效率低
在合規與監管要求下
難以實現普惠的初衷
這背後其實是世主世界
首先是風險和可得性的矛盾
銀行怕風險不敢貸
小微群體因為缺數據他也貸不到
第二個是成本與普惠性的衝突
當比的風控成本轉嫁給了客戶
與普惠的初心背道而馳
第三個效率與嚴謹性的拉扯
人工審核慢會流失客戶
繼續審核又缺少數據支撐
第四個標準化與差異化的失戀
通用模型往往不了解行業的特殊痛點
標準化的風控模型
首先他看不懂像蒼蠅店的流水特點
也讀不懂像製造小產的供應鏈的規律
所以怎麼破局呢
關鍵應該就在數據
比如說稅務、發票、物流
迫使流水、農民的土地
中央支補貼等等數據
這些上落在各地的替代數據
可以精準的渴望小微群體的真實經營狀況
而影視技術技術
正是打開這桌數據金庫的一把鑰匙
它讓銀行無需看到原始數據
就能安全地調用多方信息建模型
讓小微的群體免於反覆提交材料
12分鐘就可以拿到匹配行業特性的新代方案
這樣就真正可以做到普惠不普通
金融有溫度
這是一個在新代業務平台中
常見的受信審批策略
從預售信
進監後經過個人信息驗證
准入策略
反欺詐策略
黑名單策略
信用分控策略
闖出額度和定價
有一些會對拒絕的客戶
再進行回撈服務
每一個環節都涉及到大量的數據採集
處理和規則和模型的加工
例如在黑名單策略裏面
有內部各業務形成的一些黑名單
包括手機號、身份證號
設備ID、WiFi等
新代業務一般也會
對接外部機構的黑名單
命中外部數據員黑名單庫
則拒絕服務
在信用分控策略裏面
則是匯集了整個公司
最大量的分控數據
和指模型指標加工工作
包括規則類的
比如說央行偵信
多頭設備施法工商的數據
也包括各種分控指模型
產在模型、委員分模型等
產在模型裏面得常常是
根據經營者的資產
收入納稅等情況中和考慮
這麼多數據的匯集使用
使得金融機構
需要實時理想的匯據
置身的和外部的數據員
並搭建分銜指標計算平台
以螞蟻某信貸業務距離
從一開始的基本權
依賴生態體系內的數據
到後來逐漸外部數據
比重接近並超過了
內部數據的應用
這個分銜指標
計算平台的目標
就是回應上一頁的
小威客戶和金融機構的
信息不對稱的矛盾衝突
讓小威客戶不缺資金
並讓金融機構
不缺良好的生息資產
但是問題來了
外部數據怎麼使用呢
普徽金融領域
有一個很重要的板塊
就是服務農村客群的
信貸需求
農村群體
缺少貸礦依賴的數據支撐
農戶缺少抵押物
無信用記錄
產業數字化程度低
無法有效還原農戶資產
和生產經營情況
農汁貴的問題更加突出
從2020年開始
通過衛星搖桿識別的
創新規模劃應用
一定程度地解決
地上種什麼東西的識別
但是土地承包關係數據
以及種植相關的
農汁農機類數據
則分布在各個
商業機構
或者政府機關單位裏
一些數據類
如農民土地的坐標
由於涉及到
性感信息
在各個場景應用
還是非常敏感的
嚴格的要求數據不出於
怎麼應用呢
根據政策法律法規
和各項意見的指導項
最好的方法就是
融合農業農村大數據
和衛星搖桿
通過影視計算的方法
結合多方數據
融合建模來完成
上面講的新代裏面
需要多元數據
聯合建模的痛點
是很明顯的
卻也給我們提出了
很多的現實挑戰
現在大量的數據
都存在不同的機構裏
機構進行數據共享
存在風險
數據孤島問題
突出數據共享
日益中央
當存在買賣
洩漏
浪用等問題
數據一斤洩漏
可以被沒有成本的
無限的複製
公眾和政府
也日益重視
影視保護
歐盟GDPR
通用數據保護條例
法律正式實施
多個國家在跟進
相應的
我國的數據安全法
和個人信息保護法
讓數據共享使用
有法可依對數據
違規使用
有的嚴厲的判決
這也給金融科技行業
帶來新的難題和挑戰
在滿足安全隱私
監管的要求下
如何設計
相應的框架
實現數據的
多方協同
和授權共享
得到更準確
高效的模型和決策
進一步釋放數據價值
影視計算
也成為了
激活數據要數
互聯互通的
重要技術方法
各方在信貸領域
積極的試點和布局
前面一起看完了
普惠金融的
痛點與挑戰
我們來看一下
對應的政策指導
和標準規範
2022年12月19日
中共中央國務院
關於構建數據基礎制度
更好發揮
數據要數作用的意見
對外公佈
這就是有名的數據20條
它明確了以下幾點
首先是
數據廠權分製機制
明確公共數據
企業數據
個人數據的
分類分級
確權授權規則
建立數據資源
持有權
數據加工
使用權
數據產品
經營權分製的
產權運行機制
解決數據要數
市場化
配置中的
全數難題
鼓勵公共數據
在保護個人隱私
和確保公共
安全的前提下
按照原始數據不出於
數據可用不可見的要求
以模型
合驗等
產品和服務等形式
向社會提供服務
再是流通交易的
合規體系
要求完善數據
全流程合規
與監管規則
推動數據交易
場所規範化建設
培育數據要數
流通服務生態
並建立
跨境數據安全
有序流動機制
保障數據要數
市場化高效配置
再次
收益分配市場化原則
強調
按數據要數市場
貢獻決定報酬
政府通過稅收
調解
公共數據開放
收益防捕
等方式平衡
各方利益
確保數據價值
分配公平性
與可持續性
再次
安全治理的協同
框架
構建政府監管
企業責任
社會參與的
多方協同治理體系
明確數據安全
主體責任
強化數據分類
分級保護
與分顯評估機制
在2021年
頒發了
數據安全法
和個人信息保護法
數據安全法的
核心要求
有明確金融機構
需建立
全生命周期
數據的安全管理體系
要求對客戶身份信息
交易記錄等敏感數據
實施分類分級保護
跨境數據傳輸
需通過安全評估
規定了
開展數據處理活動的
組織
個人不履行規定的
數據安全保護
義務的
有關主管部門
責任改正
給予警告
可以秉促
相應罰款
並可以
責任暫停相關業務
停業整頓
吊銷相關業務許可證
或者吊銷營業之道
構成犯罪的
依法追究刑事責任
個人信息保護法裏的
關鍵條款有
規定金融數據處理
需遵循最小必要原則
個人信息處理者
應當根據
個人信息的處理目的
處理方式
個人信息的種類
以及對個人權益的影響
可能存在的安全風險等
採取措施
確保個人信息處理活動
符合法律行政法規的規定
並防止未經授權的訪問
以及
個人信息的洩漏
創改
丟失
包含對個人信息
實行分類管理
採取相應的加密
去標示化
等安全技術措施
違反本法規
定處理個人信息
或者處理
個人信息
為旅行本法規定的
個人信息保護義務的
情協嚴重的
由審計以上
旅行個人信息保護職責的部門
責令改正
沒收違法所得
秉處5000萬元以下
或者上一年度營業額
5%以下罰款
並可以責令暫停
相關業務
或者停業診斷
通報有關主管部門
吊銷相關業務許可
或者吊銷營業執照
我們再來看一下
一些金融相關的行業規範
個人金融信息保護技術規範
裡面有
根據信息
找到衛金授權的查看
或者衛金授權的變更後
所產生的影響和危害
將個人金融信息
按敏感程度
從高到低
分為C3 C2 C1
三個級別
C3類別信息
主要為用戶鑑別信息
該類信息
一旦找到衛金授權的查看
獲得衛金授權的變更
會對個人金融信息
主體的信息安全
與財產安全造成嚴重危害
對於C3類別信息
通過受理中端
客戶端應用軟件
瀏覽器等方式
收集時
應使用加密等技術措施
保證數據的安全性
防止其被衛授權的
第三方獲取
通過公共網絡傳輸時
C3類別信息
應使用加密通道
獲得數據加密的方式
進行傳輸
保障個人金融信息
傳輸過程的安全
對於C3類別中的
支付敏感信息
其安全傳輸技術
控制措施
應符合有關行業技術
標準
與行業主管部門的
有關規定要求
C3類別個人金融信息
應採用加密措施
確保數據存儲的安全性
應將去標示化
匿名化的數據
與可用於恢復
識別個人的信息
採取邏輯隔離的
方式進行存儲
確保取標示化
匿名化後的信息
與個人金融信息
不為混用
個人金融信息
在加工處理的過程中
具體技術要求錄下
應採取必要的技術
手段和管理措施
確保在個人金融信息清洗
和轉換過程中
對信息進行保護
對CRT3類別信息
應採取
更加嚴格的保護措施
央行金融數據安全分級指南
包括
根據
金融業機構數據安全性
遭受破壞後的影響對象
和所造成的影響程度
將數據安全級別
從高到低
劃分為5級
4級
3級
2級
1級
3級
包括
用於金融業機構關鍵
或重要業務使用
一般針對特定能源公開
且僅為必須知悉的
對象訪問和措施用
個人金融信息中的CR類信息
也就是上面說的C3類信息
可能就對應了4級了
數據的安全性遭到破壞後
對公眾權益造成一些影響
或對個人隱私貨的
企業合法權益造成一般影響
當不影響國家安全
其他的行業技術和應用規範有
多方安全計算
金融應用技術規範
聯邦學習的技術
金融應用規範
央行在
金融科技發展規劃
2022到2025年
發改委在關於進一步提升
農資信用服務平台
服務之下
深入推進新一代工作的通知中
也分別鼓勵了
隱私計算和聯邦建模
在金融信貸場景中的應用
有了以上政策和法律法規指導
數據的流通需要安全保存
隱私保護計算技術
可以在保護隱私安全的前提下
實現數據可信流通
最小化數據洩漏的可能性
從而極大的促進數據流通的發展
和降低安全風險
實現整體社會價值最大化
然而在實際應用中
各場景中的倡與方
信任程度不同
數據類型不同
各方在不同的場景裡
需要達到的數據可控程度
也是不同的
因此隱私保護計算產品
需要安全分級方法
為實際產品選型提供指導
螞蟻科技集團股份有限公司
和中國通信標準化協會
大數據技術標準推進委員會
深圳國家金融科技
測評中心清華大學
在2024年發布了
隱私計算產品
通用安全分級白皮書
也在啟動相應的
行業標準制定
金融業隱私計算產品
安全分級要求
了解了上面的
政策指導和標準規範
我們可以在新代場景中
進行隱私融合計算方案的選擇
我們在這裡列舉出來
以往工作中設計的
和行業案例中常見的
隱私融合計算方案
各方案之間不完全獨立和並列
首先是模型透明 SDK
這個實際上不設計
多方機構的數據融合計算
只是設計一般的數據
和另外一般模型的部署應用
金融產品中常用
結合機器學習和差分隱私等技術
對單一機構的數據
進行指標加工和透明
再來是
多方安全計算NPC
適用以不能直接共享
原始數據的場景
它是通過密碼學協議
保證每個參與方的數據
對其他參與方保密
計算過程保持加密狀態
第三類是聯邦學習
它的基本原理是
分布式機器學習技術
允許多個設備和機構
在不交換本地數據的情況下
訓練模型及局部模型
到全局模型的工作
這就是密碼計算T1
通過硬件手段
串建一個與主操作系統隔離的
安全可信的區域
區域內的代碼和數據
受到保護
適用於高性能的數據處理
數據隔離等場景
另外就是一些
常見的技術方法
像差分隱私
是一種數學框架
通過添加噪聲
到查詢結果
來保護個人記錄
它適合發布統計數據
或者分析結果的場景
框架密是一種允許在
不接觸原始數據下
直接對密穩進行
計算的加密技術
適合強硬是要求的
複雜計算
包括雲端計算和外包計算
金融機構如歐洲央行
建議用框架密來保護數據
以應對現在切密
未來解密的量子威脅
再就是一個比較常見的
私有集合囚交
PSI等等
利用密碼學協議
允許多個參與方
計算各自持有集合的交集
不洩漏交集以外的任何信息
用來做用戶的壯庫的使用
數據要數的流轉和互聯互通
都是在滿足數據安全法
和個人信息保護法等法律法規
在用戶明確授權的前提下開展的
在數據斷子鏈的背景下
真信業務管理辦法
有監管的核心要求可以概括為
個人的金融數據必須通過
持牌真信機構獲取
企業公共數據鼓勵通過
政府授權渠道
獲得地方真信平台對接
嚴禁銀行等金融機構
與互聯網平台數據公司
直接開展數據交易
因此在信貸業務中
我們可以通常把
真信機構和金融科技機構
歸類為數據加工方
做數據爭執服
他們通常需要代為匯聚
和加工第三方的機構的數據
因此可以使用
密泰計算的TE的方式
構建密泰輸牛
進行高性能的大數據處理服務
對於強隱私要求的複雜計算
則更加可以採用
同胎加密進行外包計算
和雲端計算
另外真信機構可以
倡導行業聯盟
採用多方安全計算
NPC等等
共享七大黑名單等數據
數據提供班中
商業機構為了
盡可能地避免
數據洩漏商業機密
它可以採用
模型透明SDK
政府機構
則對於一些數據
嚴格遵循數據不出易的方式
可以私有化部署
密泰計算TE的方式
來處理金融機構的
數據申請使用
金融機構既作為數據
所有方又作為數據使用方
在聯合分控建模的場景
它可以採用
多方安全計算NPC的方式
構建密泰管道
可以做到
模型訓練太運行太數據
都不出於
看完了上面的方案選擇
我們來實際看一下
多方聯合建模
在信貸場景中的實際應用
下面我們講一些
在信貸行業方面的
具體時間案例
聯營信貸場景的背景是
金融分控場景數據
多方安全合規水位較高
傳統的數據融合方案
有數據洩漏風險
難以滿足合規訴求
針對普惠客戶
金融分控場景
需要多維數據
提高分控效果
單一的數據
無法滿足業務的訴求
這裡是通過
螞蟻分動
多方安全計算平台
基於影視計算框架
營餘進行了
多方安全聯合建模
兩家聯營的金融機構
採用了
營餘NPC金融分控
安全全聯路解決方案
提升了各個環節的
安全等級
雙方擁有共同的客戶
互補的特徵維度
通過聯合模型
實現了優化審批通過率
降低了新客戶的風險
加強了代中風控管理等
具體的
兩家銀行
針對代前A卡
代中B卡
分別進行了建模
產出了共計四個模型
與單一機構
提供的數據元建模
效果相比
雙方聯合建模的模型
KS只可以提高10%
案例已經在累計
20多個金融機構落地應用
阻止了數十億的
高風險貸款的發放
增加了
識別數十萬的
低風險客戶
根據應用場景的不同
應用聯合模型
可以實現優化
審批通過率
降低新客戶風險
加強代中風控管理等
金融分控全聯路方案
在保護數據源頭方
信息不洩露的前提下
可以將更多維度的
應用數據納入到聯合模型中
從而構建更精準的
大數據信用分控模型
該技術方案的支持
可增進金融分控聯合項目
參與與彼此之間必要的
協同與溝通
加速金融分控管理模式
由傳統手段
向前沿技術的轉型
服務與政府
與金融業協同監管
更好的促進
金融數據要素的
市場建設
第二個是
在新代仿七大場景中
是一些用戶
在多家貸款平台
進行貸款欺詐
而新代機構
由於自己
黑名單數據的有限
無法有效地控制
七大風險
另外一家機構
查詢的路倉
由於就是
即時機構
單前申請的客戶
帶有業務屬性
查詢方往往不希望
自己的查詢路倉
被數據提供方
和中心方獲取
因此
數據孤島的行程
讓識別跨平台
貸款七大行為
很有挑戰
尤其是針對
高風險客群
需要有效的識別
以控制的七大風險
具體方案
可以構建一個
有含業機構
組成的
七大聯盟
通過
逆中查詢PIR
的隱石計算技術
查詢班機構D
對用戶
張桑
發起聯盟內
所有
參與機構
黑名單的查詢
各個合作機構ABC
則返回了密探職
根據返回職
機構D
可以推動出來
張桑是否命中
機構ABC的黑名單
機構ABC
不知道
查詢的具體是誰
通過這類方案
可以解決
機構建的互信的難題
實現
含業反七大黑名單共享
提升參與方
反七大模型的識別率
和反七大的
封控能力
並破解
含業數據孤島
提升
同業反七大
聯防聯控水平
下面我們講一個
很重要的
政府數據合作案例
今年五月份
在福州舉行的
數據中國建設峰會上
網商銀行
農村金融創新服務
入選了國家數據局
數據藥術城的典型案例
該服務
由農業農村部
大數據發展中心
與網商銀行聯合發起
在螞蟻集團的
飲食計算技術的應用下
將農業大數據
引入了金融封控
結合衛星搖桿
大三缺封控系統
為小農戶提供了
秒匹毛袋
隨即收還了
普惠金融服務
截至2020年底
超1300萬的農戶
通過這一服務
獲得了銀行的貸款額度
其中小農戶
是主要的獲益者
近八成
為種植面積
拾姆以下的小農戶
為以往金融服務中
難以覆蓋的毛袭血管
這一毛市中
在農業農村部
大數據發展中心
和網商銀行
聯合部署了
基於新站
提議的
密泰時空計算系統
該系統在
可信執行環境中
集成了分布式
時空集群
對搖桿和土地
地塊等時空數據
進行了
安全可靠的
高效的處理
在確保
農業農村
大數據不出於的
前提下
對網商銀行授權用戶
融合了
搖桿分空數據
地理位置數據
能土地基礎數據
農地城堡數據
全量的地圖數據
聯合建模
產出了
農戶的
種植指標等數據
這裡由於
TE的系統
碎化不處在
一方的數據機構內部
因此
因為操作時
數據使用班
和數據所有班
因為系統時
需要有權限管理
和審批健全等操作
做到基本的
話語管控
這個案例
也錄下了
中國信通院的
2020年
大數據新核的案例
具體的
密泰時空計算法
採用了
製度可控的
Hype Inclave
加Occlone的提議方
支持海光
國產CPU等
新創的硬件平台
性能根據
國家金融信息
安全基礎設施構建
代碼經過
權威機構審查認證
具備金融科技產品認證
安全性經過
形式化證明
TE能力
完整的實現
包括隔離執行
遠程證明
內存加密
數據分印等等
軟件的生態完整
支持主流數據庫
和大數據框架
兼容SGX
SDK
ROTSGX
SDK等已有的TE生態
並有的
農區化設計理念
簡化了應用揭露的成本
在業務系統中
我們移植了
分布式的Portgrace
加Portgrease
數據庫
對雙方的數據
包括搖桿識別數據
金融服務名單
行政區化數據
土地搖桿數據
等等
進行高效率的處理
這一套業務系統
目前可以支持
機構車
使TV量級的
數據分析處理工作
如果數據規模
再大一些
例如到幾百TV
甚至PB級別
我們建議是
利用密態計算
大數據框架
例如密態SPARC
來進行高效的處理
這在我們
另外一個部位業務中
也已經應用
這裡再簡單說一下
密態計算TE的
業務系統
如何保障
端道端的
全聯絡
應用數據的安全
首先確保
Oklon數據庫
和應用實力的
進向膽包的安全
通過MSI
TVM芯片
新聞根
對應用程序的
簽名
確保系統
不可運行
沒有認證過
TE的應用程序
通過TE內部
產生應用的
公司藥對
確保私藥
在TE外面不可解
公藥通過
安全通道導出後
作為網站銀行
通過新聞加密
支撐數據
包括授權名單
和作務識別等數據
由於加密特性
不管傳輸方式
是互聯網
傳輸
還是物理拷貝的
池盤傳輸方式
加密後的數據
只能傳輸到
部署在政府單位的
TE機器
在TE內部的
受信應用中
進行解密計算
參與計算的數據
在內存中
是通過Memory Key
自動加密的
在池盤的
持久化存儲後
則通過
CO Key
安全的加密保存
因此可以做到
網站銀行的數據
在機構冊的
單位環境中
存儲態
和運行態的
加密的安全
所以能做到
端道端的
安全的保障
以上都是
信貸業務
分控中的應用
我們再舉一個
信貸業務影響的案例
在一個業務中
都在科技平台
需要將用戶
導流到銀行機構
由於業務的複雜性
銀行機構這邊
仍然需要電話銀銷
現象加微信等操作
補全用戶的
各種資料數據
引導用戶進行
申請審批和支用
由於流程複雜
用戶的資金
需求匹配難度較高
用戶的流失率很高
同時也會有
銀行機構
不知道
客戶已經對
產品興趣下降後
多次騷擾客戶的
現象發生
怎麼盡可能
避免對客戶
騷擾的前提下
住在科技平台
和銀行機構
共同服務而客戶
有一個
燙手的案例是
可以通過在銀行機構
部署密探計算GP環境
加密引入
互聯網授權數據
並引入機構設
吩咐的
限量限價
被解構化的作業數據
通過語音識別模型
和意圖識別大模型
可以爭別用戶的
真實貸款訴求
結合互聯網授權數據
做更好的分控
和銀銷模型
整體環境對於
雙方都是安全可控
確保用戶敏感和
機構的機密數據不外洩
可以成為構建更好的
聯合運營策略的
一種嘗試
我們前面新代
實踐中的密探計算
都依賴於一個
安全可信的密探基礎
密探基礎
我們這邊
至底向上分了四成
在芯片硬件層面
提供了
數組機
軟硬件
環境可信的能力
抵禦針對數組機的
各類工具
如內存盔燙
系統創改
特權運位等等
在安全可信層
提供基於容器
虛擬機
GPU的機密機上
應用可信度量
和可信基礎服務能力
抵禦針對應用的
數據潰燙
後門指路
抵禦惡意程序的
非法運行
在操作系統層面
提供可信應用的
4A能力
包括身份識別
身份認證
授權控制
可追溯性的能力
在基礎服務層面
提供從代碼
到可信應用的
開發運位
一體化流程
抵禦針對
軟件供應鏈的攻擊
讓應用開發的
簡單便捷的
使用可信技術能力
最後
簡單列舉
一些影視計算
在新代應用中的
螞蟻相關的
評測和相應的認證
謝謝大家
歡迎大家多交流